we probably just witnessed the craziest
ending to an nwsl championship game ever
but unfortunately it did not start out
pretty Megan rapino who was playing her
last ever game with o rign planted her
foot wrong and was forced to be subbed
off in the third minute of the match but
as Gotham FC LED 2 to1 and was this
close to tasing Victory this play
changed the game in the 90th minute
Gotham FC goalkeeper Mandy hot picked up
a red card for legally touching the ball
outside the box and she was forced to
leave the game the easy solution would
have been to sub on backup goalie
Michelle BOS but the team had no more
substitutions left to make so they had
to put in midfielder neie Martin to
stand in goal to hold on to the lead and
they did the rain were awarded a free
kick just outside the box but their
attempt to tie the game fell short the
kick hit the wall and Gotham FC held on
so the story started off sour for Gotham
FC but they still persevered through and
left the field as champions